[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com so we've been covering what's
going on in Iran and part of that story
includes that yesterday Donald Trump
casually threatened war crimes against
Iran on Twitter threatening Iranian
cultural sites as targets which is a war
crime per the Geneva Convention it's
very cut and dry there's really no
ambiguity about that the question is are
the threats going to become actual
orders and if they become orders what is
the Pentagon what is the military
actually going to do we have some good
news if we can believe it and the
believability of it is something we'll
talk about in a second and the good news
is that the Pentagon immediately said no
we are not going to commit Donald
Trump's war crimes Secretary of Defense
mark Esper admitted yesterday I mean he
didn't even try to deny that targeting
Iranian cultural sites if they are not
otherwise military targets targets of
military value crazy world we live in
right if there is not a standalone
military value to the cultural sites it
would be a war crime and that they would
not do it and this puts mark espera and
the Pentagon directly opposite Trump who
insists that these are legitimate
targets and actually double down on the
war crime threat on Air Force One when
asked about is completely unhinged
tweets the Secretary of Defense mark
Esper said quote we will follow the laws
of armed conflict now for like a split
second I kind of felt bad for a second
for the people that have to deal with
Donald Trump and clean up his messes and
then I remembered hey choosie you can
choose whatever job you want they can
quit at any time and then I didn't feel
bad for them anymore but military
leaders are in a position where they
have to balance the law and reality and
empiricism with what Donald Trump wants
and what Don
from tweets and Donald Trump often loses
it when he does not get what he wants
Donald Trump threatening war crimes on
Twitter appears to be disturbing not
just international allies which we
talked about yesterday but it's
disturbing even our own military and our
Pentagon and the Secretary of Defense so
I have a few thoughts on this number one
if indeed the Pentagon is honest in what
they say like if we can trust mark Esper
is telling the truth when he says we're
not going to do it these are war crimes
then that's good but can we believe mark
Esper are they just saying this because
historically the United States doesn't
announce one way or the other when its
military is going to be committing war
crimes we often find out later many
times thanks to investigative journalism
document leaks sometimes FOIA requests
are part of it so this is sort of
uncharted territory where in advance the
president is saying here's an idea let's
commit some war crimes I have a list of
war crimes targets that I would like to
see targeted and then the Secretary of
Defense says no those would be war
crimes we're not going to do it this is
a very backwards way in which this
normally happens but it's conceivable
that getting this out into the open
ahead of time actually makes it less
likely by shining a spotlight on it that
it eventually happens now to keep going
with this if Mark espera is telling the
truth and he can be believed that the
Pentagon the military will not be
committing the war crimes that Donald
from threatened is Mark espers job safe
because we've seen that when a trump
administration official publicly
contradicts the word of Trump very often
they end up resigning force resignations
and Donald Trump pulls in someone who is
much more willing to do his bidding or
at least shut the hell up about it and
not make it clear that they disagree
with Donald Trump number three think
about how insane things are today that
it is newsworthy that the Pentagon is
ruling out war crimes preemptively as
suggested by the president on Twitter
this is the reality this is a head
today in 2020 number four the fact that
Donald Trump even threatened these war
crimes is still disgraceful and
potentially an escalating action and
Donald Trump is quickly moving from
being an international laughingstock to
being an international terror and number
five let's not excuse the Republican
Party at large we're going to talk later
in the show about how twenty people or
even fourteen people in the Senate and
cabinet respectively could put an end to
the worldwide fiasco that is Donald
Trump we'll get to that later not a
single Republican member of the House or
Senate have just said I condemn Donald
Trump casually threatening war crimes on
Twitter not a single one not one
Republican and that's part of why we're
in serious trouble that's part of why
this guy might get himself reelected now
to get back to the war crimes for a
moment what will happen if Donald Trump
gives the order does Marquez per se know
do the general say no in the United
States military orders are only
considered valid if they are legal if
they adhere to the United to the Uniform
Code of Military Justice the UCMJ that's
a separate branch of legal code and all
US military personnel are under oath to
follow that there's also the LOA see the
law of armed conflict there's the Geneva
Conventions and according to
international humanitarian law and I
think with many trumpets if you say to
them international humanitarian law they
just laugh right I mean they don't care
about that according to international
humanitarian law officers are not to be
punished if they refuse to carry out
orders that are known or suspected to be
illegal an order to intentionally target
cultural sites and cultural objects and
locations lacking military value would
absolutely fall under illegal under that
umbrella I don't know what we would
expect to happen technically illegal
orders are supposed to be disobeyed or
the perpetrator can be held accountable
just like that person giving the order
and in fact there's historical precedent
from this you can go back to World War
Two and the I was just following orders
defense is one that is not valid so I I
don't know we're now getting sort of
it's hugely depressing that we're even
getting into this conversation to this
degree but this is the world in 2020
under Donald Trump we have an
opportunity to end at least part of it
just ten months from now I hope that we
will take that opportunity we'll get a
little bit later in the program to the
spineless Republicans fourteen of whom
could end this national tragedy and are
choosing not to do that but first let's
talk about Democrats trying anyway to
control Donald Trump on Iran
Axios is reporting that Speaker of the
House Nancy Pelosi of course a Democrat
from California is announcing that the
House of Representatives is this week
going to quote introduce and vote on a
War Powers Resolution to limit President
Donald Trump's military actions
regarding Iran now of course if the
president does not seek approval if the
president ignores what they are supposed
to do then it's unclear how much this
will actually limit the president's
ability to do whatever he wants but
needless to say Nancy Pelosi said in her
letter quote last week the Trump
administration conducted a provocative
and disproportionate military airstrike
targeting high-level
Iranian military officials this action
endangered our servicemembers diplomats
and others by risking a serious
escalation of tensions with Iran in the
Senate senator Tim Kaine from Virginia
also a Democrat introduced a similar War
Powers Resolution now you may have
missed this but Donald Trump did file a
War Powers Resolution regarding Iran
it's super odd and it only raised even
more questions Nancy Pelosi responded by
saying this classified War Powers Act
notification delivered to Congress
raises more questions than it answers
this document prompts serious and urgent
questions about the timing manner and
justification of the administration's
decision to engage in hostility
against Iran the highly unusual decision
to classify this document in its
entirety compounds our many concerns and
suggests that the Congress and the
American people are being left in the
dark about our national security
can you imagine he says under Obama
Trump does you need congressional
authorization to do this type of thing
then he just does it files a War Powers
Resolution but immediately classifies it
so nobody has any idea what's actually
in it but then pretends like he's doing
everything on the up-and-up so as far as
the War Powers Resolution that Nancy
Pelosi is introducing in the house and
Tim Kaine is introducing in the Senate
anybody voting no on this should be held
to account and have to give an actual
explanation for why they are voting no
of course every Democrat should vote YES
on this Republicans who say they believe
in the rule of law Republicans who say
they believe in the Constitution
Republicans who say that checks and
balances and separation of powers matter
should all be voting yes as well but I
would not necessarily expect them to do
that if you needed any more evidence
that Donald Trump has no idea how any of
this stuff works and just how out of
control he is look at what Donald Trump
tweeted yesterday he tweeted that his
tweets serve as notifications to
Congress look at how insane this is
Trump tweeting quote these media posts
and he capitalizes the Amman media and
the peon posts and maybe he believes
that that makes it official in some way
these media posts will serve as
notification to the United States
Congress that should Iran's strike any
US person or target the United States
will quickly and fully strike back and
perhaps in a disproportionate manner
such legal notice is not required but is
given that nevertheless that's not how
Twitter works tweeting stuff from the
bathroom on your phone are does not do
that does not qualify as legal notice
it's not how Twitter works it's not how
the presidency works and what we have if
we step back is an impeached president
threatening war crimes on Twitter like I
told you yesterday and using Twitter as
a notification tool I guess to Congress
about me
pterri action if we don't take the
country back from this law breaking
insanity what happens next
I'm all of a sudden becoming right-wing
in my opinion of executive power and the
power of the office of the presidency I
got a call a couple of weeks ago from a
viewers saying hey David are you a
right-winger on anything and I really
couldn't think of anything
maybe I am starting to be a small
government conservative in the sense
that the Trump administration is
exposing that the presidency has too
much unchecked power we've seen
unchecked power used before in to some
degree we've seen Barack Obama with the
drones we've seen george w bush but
we've talked about this before but
generally speaking the left is not
particularly keen on stripping more and
more power from the office of the
presidency maybe my mind is being
changed because I'm seeing what Donald
Trump is doing Trump's antics Trump's
belligerents Trump's ignorant show
exactly why a single person and one
office the office of the presidency
should not be allowed to hold this much
power but really what it comes down to
is the lack of effectiveness and
efficacy of the checks and balances when
we go back to the founding fathers and
the ways that they structure checks and
balances they clearly never imagined
that you would have a president like
Donald Trump that would just flout those
norms and laws and framework and it
seems as though our elected officials
are either unable or unwilling our
justice system is unable or unwilling
probably a combination of both to
actually employ those checks and
balances in a way that limits what
Donald Trump is able to do at the same
time in a sense Trump doesn't have that
much power because they could remove him
tomorrow if the entire Republican Party
hadn't decided to let him do whatever he
wants 20 Republicans is all it would
take in the Senate during the
impeachment trial to remove Donald Trump
14 members of the cabinet 13 plus mike
pence or is it 14 plus Mike Pence could
remove Donald Trump under the 25th
amendment but they don't and that makes
him effectively Omni omnipotence
endlessly powerful it is a dystopian
nightmare we'll talk a little bit more
later about the 14 Republicans or the 20
Republicans in the meantime what do you
think is ultimately going to happen in
Iran we are talking about this on a
variety of our platforms let me know via
tweet at D Pakman what do you believe
ultimately will happen in Iran we'll
take a quick break and be back after
this the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com let me thank two great people
who recently signed up for david pakman
show membership spill McSherry and
elaine Arrigo Gilyard phil and elaine
thank you so much for your support
particularly in this new year election
year I think our tally is up to about
two thirty or so two hundred and thirty
new members this month so far taking
advantage of that huge membership
special that we ran on January 1st still
a few remaining realize I mean it's
unlimited anybody who wants it can have
it just email me if you want the coupon
code for the twenty twenty discount I
will send that to you also want to say
thanks to Jean Stanley jeans been a
member for almost five years and is
today's longtime sustaining member of
the day join these great folks by
picking up a membership at join
pakman.com we do have big news that I
don't want to go overly crazy about
because of how it will probably turn out
the big news is that Donald Trump's
former national security adviser one of
trumps former national security advisors
john bolton one of the architects of the
Iraq war says he's willing to testify in
the Senate impeachment trial of Donald
Trump he says he would do it if he is
subpoenaed that's typical in these
situations to say you will show up if
you are subpoenaed because you don't
want to be accused of willingly showing
up to bad-mouth someone but it's not
totally clear that that's actually what
john bolton would do we just don't know
bolton said in a statement yesterday
quote i have concluded that if the
senate issues a subpoena for my
testimony I am prepared to testify now
of course whether he would be subpoenaed
by a Republican Senate is a real open
question Republicans are likely to run
the trial as Mitch McConnell has
admitted in the way that's most
beneficial to Donald Trump after Bolton
and Trump's falling out it's very
difficult to imagine that a Bolton
testimony would actually be in Donald
Trump's interest but nevertheless Trump
Bolton rather publicly saying this does
put some pressure on Republicans
to bring him in now Marco Rubio
Republican senator from Florida came up
with a completely cockamamie excuse for
why he doesn't think Bolton should
testify it was something about I'm
paraphrasing here I think he said it's a
man who razo of CNN it was something
along the lines of well the impeachment
articles were based not on John Bolton's
testimony so I think that the
impeachment trial in the Senate should
be based on the same things that the
articles were voted on in the house sort
of saying like if Bolton wasn't part of
the proceedings in the house he
shouldn't be called in the Senate it was
ridiculous you know a number of
different legal analyses say it makes no
sense whatsoever now as an update the
president has been impeached by the
House of Representatives Speaker of the
House Nancy Pelosi has not yet sent the
articles of impeachment both there's two
of them to the Senate which is required
to get the trial going remember that
John Bolton previously declined to
participate in the houses impeachment
investigation saying that he was
directed by the Trump administration not
to comply with Congress he said if you
subpoena me if federal courts uphold the
subpoena I will testify the committee's
ultimately did not issue a subpoena for
his testimony now there is something
interesting about the subpoena of John
Bolton many things in the Senate require
a two-thirds majority to impeach a
president and convict them in the Senate
you need a two-thirds majority you need
two-thirds of senators meaning 67 of the
hundred senators to vote to convict
right now there are 45 Democrats and two
independents who caucus with Democrats
that's 47 votes in the Senate you would
need 20 Republican senators to vote to
convict in order to remove Donald Trump
not likely to happen to subpoena John
Bolton you need only a simple majority
meaning 51 senators that means you need
the 45 Democrats the two independents
who caucus with Democrats Bernie Sanders
and angus King and then just for
Republicans to sign on to subpoena john
bolton you actually could make this
happen if we go to our standard list of
Republicans who might do something
logical you've got Susan Collins from
May
you've got Lisa Murkowski from Alaska
you've got maybe Mitt Romney from Utah
people talk about over about what about
Cory Gardner from Colorado it's possible
the idea of Bolton being willing to
testify if subpoenaed is also funny if
you were subpoenaed you were required by
law to show up they're talking about it
like it's a choice and he would make the
right choice now that's an issue that
maybe will come up if Bolton is
unwilling to respond to the subpoena or
if it is challenged by the White House
and it goes to federal courts but Donald
Trump clearly will do what he can to
prevent John Bolton from ultimately
testifying imagine being Bolton who has
loved the idea of war with Iran for so
long and now Trump waits until you're
gone before trying to start a war with
Iran he must just be furious in his
neocon boots don't you think now as far
as people getting super excited about
Bolton's testimony even if he subpoenaed
and even if the subpoena is upheld by a
federal court and Bolton has to testify
he could choose to obfuscate unimportant
issues he could plead the fifth on
important issues Bolton will do what is
best for John Bolton and that might be
showing up in obfuscating it might be
showing up in self-aggrandizing it might
be showing up and saying nothing this
guy is not only is he no hero he's
really one of the villains of American
foreign policy over the last 20 years
and of course of the Iraq war the only
good thing here is that it puts a little
bit of pressure on Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell to allow
witnesses because otherwise it would
look like they are trying to silence
Bolton which they probably are but once
again if there's no consequences for
silencing John Bolton why wouldn't they
do it it wouldn't make a difference
recall that according to President
Donald Trump Hillary Clinton could not
be trusted to handle sensitive secret
and classified information we've now
learned that random guests at Donald
Trump's Florida Resort mar-a-lago knew
more about the plan to assassinate
Iranian leader Kasim Soleimani
then did our own members of Congress
according to a new report
Congress was not informed of the
administration's planned military attack
on sulemani our European allies as I
told you yesterday were not informed per
the Daily Beast's during the days
leading up to the assassination of
soleimani Trump started to drop quote
hints to close associates and club goers
that something huge was coming and quote
specifically mentioned he'd been in
close contact with his top national
security and military advisers on gaming
out options for an aggressive action
that could quickly materialize Donald
Trump was reportedly walking around his
Club mar-a-lago in Florida saying he had
a big response planned to Iran that
people would be reading about it quote
very soon and meanwhile he was tweeting
about Iran having to pay a big price he
kept saying you'll see one of the
sources recalled describing a
conversation with trump days before
Thursday's strike totally cool totally
legal a totally responsible thing for a
president to do random people at
mar-a-lago had more of a hint that
something was upcoming on Iran a bigger
hint than the gang of eight had in
Congress never mind the total lack of
congressional authorization that Trump
claimed presidents needed back when
Trump wasn't president and Barack Obama
was it is absolutely unconscionable that
the mar-a-lago thing has been allowed to
continue but why wouldn't it there have
been no consequences to anything that
Donald Trump does if you want access to
Trump you can get it by signing up for a
membership at mar-a-lago $200,000
initiation fee $14,000 a year in dues
this is a direct funnel of money from
people to Trump's businesses for access
to the President of the United States
even to a front row seat of Trump
mishandling sensitive national security
information but we don't have to worry
because his don't he's donating his
$400,000 salary so it's all fine people
whose names we don't even know get to
hear from Trump about sensitive plans
while my taxpayer dollars and your
taxpayer dollars are funneled into
Donald Trump's Club for security rooms
for Trump staffers
rooms for Secret Service golf cart
rentals shrimp cocktail for Donald Trump
if I were a foreign diplomat I would
immediately just sign up for a
mar-a-lago membership it's not an
extravagance
it's a geopolitical investment at this
point in time why do you think the
initiation fee doubled at mar-a-lago
from $100,000 to $200,000 after Donald
Trump was elected president this is
profiteering
but it's profiteering that puts national
security at risk and it's profiteering
on the basis of president of the of a
President of the United States
essentially selling access to himself at
his club it's happening blatantly is
happening boldly and there are actually
suggestions that the stock trades of
mar-a-lago members should be
investigated to look for patterns and
see if there's evidence of insider
trading on the basis of Donald Trump
saying things while roaming the halls is
this the type of winning we were told we
would get under President Donald Trump
this is a red alert Danger and after our
interview I am going to talk about we
increasingly need to be putting the
pressure on Republican elected officials
who are unwilling to deal with this
Trump is horrible the people around him
are horrible there's no question about
it
but we talk about oh we might need 65 or
70 million votes to remove this guy in
November of 2020 20 Republicans could do
it
14 cabinet members could do it and we'll
talk about that a little bit later in
the meantime make sure to vote in our
poll about what you think will happen in
Iran follow the david pakman show on
instagram at david pakman show and while
you're there follow me on instagram at
david dot hackers quick break and much
more
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome back to the david
pakman show it's great to welcome to the
program today had Rick Smith who's the
executive producer of the democracy
rebellion where Hedrick travels the
country really looking for success
stories of democratic reform which is I
mean you know that what I find
interesting about this Hedrick is that
there's so much negative going on and
it's not about pretending that
everything is great but I think it is
important to understand when there are
opportunities to make positive change we
want to understand both what they are
but it seems a focus for you also is
understanding how they can be replicated
elsewhere is that a piece of what you're
trying to do but you got a bundle the
things there first place I didn't
actually go looking for successes I was
traveling the country I'd written a book
called who stole the American Dream
about how we got the inequality in this
country and people started peppering me
at my college lectures and talks with
other groups how are we going to fix
this as anybody doing anything about it
so I really kind of stumbled into the
story and I began to find that there
were people doing something about
student debt about minimum wage and then
they were doing something about
gerrymandering and dark money and voter
suppression and things like that and I
said wow this is a story and it's not
being reported and if you're a good
reporter finding a story that's good and
that nobody else is reporting or not
doing much about that's what you want to
go after and I was a foreign
correspondent for the New York Times for
a long time Moscow Cairo Saigon Paris I
learned then you can't cover a country
by sitting in the capital and that's
what our Washington press corps is doing
and one of the reasons is the story is
really negative here
it's partisanship it's gridlock its
lobbyists taking over Congress it's
corporations capturing the Congress and
people being left out but if you get out
into Colorado or
contender North Carolina or Florida or
South Dakota of all places Connecticut
Massachusetts people are on the move and
they're fixing things and I just thought
that's a tremendous story a lot of the
stories you stories you tell relate to
money and politics in some way shape or
form sometimes it's very direct it's
literally about money sometimes it's
more indirectly related to the influence
that one can buy or wield if they have
access to money sometimes hidden money
in different ways is this the number one
theme in a sense that what we need to be
looking at as a starting point is the
way that money flows into politics or is
there some other theme that you would
assign to the stories that you found the
most important theme is that people
power works as if there's an enormous
dissatisfaction and anger and
disenchantment among the American people
today with the political system a sense
that Washington and politicians don't
listen to people like me that the big
money has captured Congress and the
government is working for special
interests and along with that there's a
widespread feeling of powerlessness of
hopelessness there's nothing we can do
about it they've got all the money
they've got a lock on power we can't get
them out of office they won't listen to
us and a friend of mine Ernie Cortez
who's an organizer down in Texas in the
southwest said to me at one point you
know Rick people say power corrupts
absolute power corrupts absolutely he
said but powerlessness powerlessness
also corrupts it corrupts democracy at
the core but what astonished me was that
there is I don't know 8 to 8 percent 10
percent 15 percent 20 percent of people
out there who say damn it I'm gonna do
something about it we got to take this
on ourselves that's the main theme the
main theme is that people power does
work I mean last year 20 last election
2018 was the best year for political
reform in this country in half a century
five states adopted gerrymander reform
three adopted electoral form seven or
eight states made it easier to vote four
or five big cities adopted public
funding of campaigns Maine adopted rank
order voting there they're now 13 states
signed on to change the elect
to a college so reform is actually
springing up all over the place so
that's the main theme yes money is a big
deal but gerrymandering is another big
deal anyway people can get a lock on
power either by manipulating election
maps or by using dark money and big
money that's dangerous to democracy and
people are reacting and that's great
yeah there's been some successes when it
comes to gerrymandering we saw what
happened in North Carolina we saw what
happened in Florida what I'm interested
in hearing from you about this is
gerrymandering is extraordinarily
important and impactful but for a lot of
people who are just through no fault of
their own they're just busy living their
lives they're trying to put food on the
table they're going to work and doing
these things it's not an issue that as
many people are aware of as maybe should
be what was it that you believe took
place in the places where they've had
successes that created the activism and
the awareness of this as an issue like
what's the difference maker with regard
to getting people engaged and saying
this is an issue we can activate around
let's do it speaking up and doing some
of the about it in Michigan a young
woman named Katie Faye 28 years old
posted a post on Facebook this is back
in 2017 posted on Facebook that
gerrymander was going on in Michigan
that the state Republicans in the state
legislature had tilted the scales and so
instead of there being a sort of a 50/50
split in the state's legislature and the
state's delegation to Congress which is
about what the popular vote was there
was a real tilt in favor of the
Republicans so she writes this on
Facebook within a week she got 5,000
responses she set up a group called
voters not politicians meaning voters
should draw the lines voters should
decide not politicians drawing the map
she understood that Jerry Manning was
stacking the deck and therefore it was
affecting everything else it was
affecting how they voted on minimum wage
on student debt on immigration on gun
control everything else now what happens
is usually people focus on their issue
and that's understandable there's
certain issues that really grab people
aggravate them they want to do something
about it
but what Katie Fey and others have
understood
is that fixing gerrymandering fixing
money and politics fixing voters rights
is the gateway to the issues that you
want to get to if the system is tilted
and stacked in favor of special
interests then no matter how how loud
you scream no matter how much you
organize you can't change it and I think
that's a real awareness I don't know
what it is why they responded the answer
was a whole lot of people in Michigan
understood what Katie Fahey said and
when she finally lit the match it struck
a spark and there it went
but it's interesting it wasn't just
Michigan I mean it happened in Missouri
it happened in Colorado it happened in
Ohio you know it happened in Utah in
North Dakota there's a bunch of 70 year
old women who call themselves the listen
to this the badass grandmas of theirs 70
years old there are half a dozen of them
they said we have a corrupt political
system we got foreign money coming in we
got lobbyists with too much power we're
not limiting contributions they
literally passed a referendum and North
Dakota pushed by the grant passed
grandma's now I can't tell you why it
took off I think the answer is there's
so much tinder out there there's so much
anger there's so much frustration with
an unfair political system that if the
person lights the right match it takes
off and the answer is it's taken off in
state after state so there's no special
magic I think the key is people hanging
in there and people getting over that
sense that we're powerless we can't do
it and I think that's the reason why our
movie the democracy rebellion is really
important because it shows people that
in states is different as North Carolina
and South Dakota California and Florida
Connecticut at Washington people power
has worked it's not just a dream it's
not just what you learned in high school
it's not just civics it's actually
happening and I think when people see it
they'll see and the guy says at the end
of the documentary it's a wonderful line
a guy named Jorge Missoula who's a
Latino organizer and Miami he says if we
can do it in Florida you can do it in
your state I think that's the message is
there a or let me let me frame it up in
a different way there are different
mechanisms through which we can achieve
change so sometimes it's
voting for someone different to
represent us in a particular you know
state Senate House of Representatives
whatever
there are ballot initiatives that
sometimes have been successful at
achieving change there are legal appeals
so filing lawsuits and appealing those
up to a high enough level at which a
change can be adjudicated are different
mechanisms more or less appropriate for
different goals or is there one
mechanism that you believe is most
effective so the more errors you have in
your query the better off you are the
people the people for example in North
Carolina who were working the moral
Monday movement in North Carolina which
was working against a ID law that one of
the court said was targeted with
surgical precision to affect the voting
of african-american voters oh yes so
they went to court and they filed suit
and eventually they won that Court
decision but they also had
demonstrations outside the state capitol
moral Monday they started out with a
dozen or two dozen people and they wound
up at one point with 80,000 people on
one Monday
so they used mass demonstrations both to
show the legislators the lawmakers that
they had to respond to public opinion
but also to mobilize people and actually
that's effective the way elections are
starting to go in North Carolina it
mobilized people not just for that issue
but it gave people the idea that if they
came out they could influence the state
government they actually want to
congressional a governor's election in
North Carolina so that I mean the
politics of North Carolina have begun to
change as a result of the protest
movement so this note there's no silver
bullet there's no one answer it matter
of fact the more techniques that are
used the better chance of success a
protest movement or a democracy
rebellion has and then if it just tries
one thing there are people who will hear
our conversation and certainly with a
will agree with the outcomes of many of
the stories that are told in the film
but they will no doubt still say listen
at the national level when it comes to
what we see happening in the White House
we feel helpless we see that there are
checks and balances but they're being
ignored
we see that there has been an
impeachment which even if it were to go
to the Senate would ultimately be an
acquittal when it comes to how the
Senate would vote and they feel
powerless what do you say to people who
are concerned about at the national
level what they've felt has been an
inability despite what Donald Trump has
done no matter what it is that has taken
place that they feel as though it's just
a matter of either we vote him out in
November or we don't and otherwise we
feel like we don't have that much power
to affect change well if you're gonna go
mountain climbing you don't start up by
by going after Everest you start with a
hill in your own neighborhood and you
climb it and then you learn how to climb
a Berryhill I mean I think the answer is
if you're looking at what's going on in
the Senate when you're looking what's
going on in the Congress those are
directly affected by the reforms that
are taking place at the state level now
if Donald Trump is defeated in November
the reform movements I'm talking about
will have had something to do with
mobilizing people and giving them a
sense of power you know politics is not
a light switch you can't throw a light
switch and say oh well if I go out and
demonstrate today I get whatever it is I
want politically tomorrow you got to
build for it you got to work for it I
mean I mean Trump's election whether or
not people liked it or not was a mark of
enormous dissatisfaction by at least 60
million American people not that Hillary
Clinton got but they were very unhappy
with the party on the other side you got
to acknowledge that part of the
difficulty is we get so locked into our
point of view that we think well we're
right and the other side is totally
wrong and there's no justification there
the answer is you got to go out persuade
people well one way you persuade people
is you get involved in a movement one of
the things that that is data that has
really struck me about this movement is
how trans partisan it is when I go into
a Colorado or I go into a Connecticut or
I go into Florida I find Republicans
independents and Democrats all working
on it if I'm in Washington for I sit and
where I live and where I've done my
political reporting most of my life I
see it just absolute cleavage I see a
Grand Canyon there used to be an overlap
in the parties of politicians I mean the
political scientists used to do charts
and they actually
plotted the votes of the Democrats in
the house and the Republicans in the
House and they overlapped and today
there's a gulf between them they
actually chart them two maps and they
look different that's not the case out
in the country so the police where we're
gonna get the country back is out there
and by the way that's American history I
mean the civil rights movement didn't
start in Washington they passed the
Civil Rights Act of 1964 in the Voting
Rights Act of 1965 after years of
protest at the grassroots so if you were
sitting at the grassroots if you were
involved in the Montgomery bus boycott
in 1955 you had to wait six seven eight
nine years before it happened but it did
happen and you had an impact on I was in
Birmingham I was in Albany Georgia I was
in Nashville Tennessee I saw the thing
built and what I'm seeing as a reporter
today is the same kind of building it
will yield results it is already
yielding results at the state level the
democracy rebellion is leading it is
getting those results it will lead
results to the national level we saw it
with a progressive era a century ago
women got the right to vote we got
direct election the Senators we've had
this kind of period in American history
before we shot it's smart to take heart
it's smart to take inspiration and not
to do what Ernie Cortez said feel
powerless because you can't knock the
guy off in the way you want at the
moment I understand that frustration but
politics takes time I mean it's a little
bit like watching grass growing I mean
if you watch their lawn you can't see
any change but if you were there in the
spring and it was bare ground and you're
there in the fall and there's a lawn you
understand something was happening
that's what I think is going on in
America today the grass is growing the
the land is fertile the people are
moving it works it's amazing I mean I
have to tell you as a reporter who's
reported for five decades he's been all
over the world I've reported from 40
countries or so I'm amazed at what I'm
seeing and I'm as a citizen I'm really
encouraged we've been speaking about the
film the democracy rebellion with the a
film's executive producer Hedrick Smith
Hedrick I really appreciate your time
today and I encourage the audience to
absolutely check out
film be great to have people watch it I
think you'll take heart ill inspire you
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
there's a pretty good piece in
Washington monthly by David Atkins which
reminds us that for all of the bad
that's taking place in the United States
right now it's important not to lose
sight of what's just a simple reality
that twenty Republicans in the Senate
could end the national nightmare that is
Donald Trump and I would actually go
even further 14 Republicans could remove
Donald Trump we talk about Trump as this
national disease this virus that has
infected tens of millions of people with
seemingly overwhelming numbers necessary
to remove in November of 2020 election
will we need sixty-two million votes
will we need sixty four will we need
seventy million votes depending on which
states those votes come in to remove
Donald Trump there are actually some
tiny groups of people that could remove
the president if they had a backbone if
they decided that they were going to do
the right thing rather than the partisan
thing so let's first start with David
Atkins piece David Atkins piece reminds
us that quote the most accountable
people in America now are the Craven
Republican elected officials who have
the power to stop this yet refused to
and Atkins goes on to say all it would
take is 20 Republican senators to say no
to say that enough is enough
to put the interests of the United
States ahead of their temporary partisan
interests it would only take well under
half of the Republicans Senate caucus to
do the right thing and Atkins points out
this wouldn't even be that bad for the
Republican Party in the end you get Mike
Pence right it would even cost them it
wouldn't even cost them that much as a
party he writes Democrats are extremely
unlikely to lose the house in 2020 hence
the large number of Republican
retirements the Senate is likely to be
deadlocked getting rid of Trump would
still leave Mike Pence in the White
House with the ability to nominate
extremists Federalist Society judges
David Atkins is completely right but
it's actually even worse it's not just
20 Republicans in the Senate there is an
even smaller group that could remove
Donald Trump because under the 25th
amendment just 14 people could remove a
sitting president the 25th amendment
outlines a process for removing a
president who is either unable or unfit
to serve section four of the 25th
amendment allows the vice president and
a majority of the cabinet to remove the
president from office under that fourth
section it would take fourteen people to
remove Donald Trump vice president Mike
Pence and thirteen of the 24 cabinet
members section four reads will put it
up on the screen
whenever the vice president and a
majority of either the principal
officers of the executive departments or
of such other body as Congress may by
law provide transmit to the president
pro tempore of the Senate and the
Speaker of the House of Representatives
their written declaration that the
president is unable to discharge the
powers and duties of his office
the vice president shall immediately
assumed the powers and duties of the
office as acting president this is a
very quick and simple process in a sense
consider the immorality of being able to
end this national nightmare among a
group of just 20 Republicans in the
Senate among a group of 14 Republicans
in the cabinet including Mike Pence and
choosing not to do it this is the virus
of political partisanship and cronyism
that we've been talking about will I
talked earlier in the show we just need
for Republicans to say let's subpoena
john bolton for republicans in the
senate and then we can do it that gets
us a simple majority we will be
hard-pressed to find four Republican
senators who are willing just to do the
very milquetoast uncontroversial thing
of subpoenaing john bolton to testify in
Donald Trump's impeachment trial
forget about 14 Republicans in the
cabinet or 20 Republicans in the Senate
but my bet if I were to bet is they go
down with the ship or try to outlast
this there is ZERO indication that any
of these people want to be a part of the
solution or that they even really agree
about what the solution is good luck
finding 20 Republicans with a conscience
let alone Republican senators you would
have better luck getting Santa the Tooth
Fairy and the Easter Bunny to remove
Donald Trump in 20
then you would finding 20 Republican
senators or 14 Republican cabinet
members to make it a reality we're going
to have to do it without them and I can
you know it when I said this a year and
a half ago it felt like maybe it wasn't
the case a year and a half ago I was
saying Trump clearly should be impeached
Trump clearly should be removed under
the 25th amendment something seems
cognitively wrong something is very
wrong in terms of the degree of
corruption that this guy is
participating in but a year and a half
ago I was saying I still believe the
Moller report isn't going to do it
impeachment isn't going to do it
November of 2020 is very quickly going
to become the first soonest and best
opportunity to remove the guy we're now
only just under you know ten ten months
- a week away from the November of 2020
election it is becoming clearer and
clearer that that is the quickest most
efficient and most direct way to remove
the guy I hope we recognize that I hope
we don't allow the activism that so many
people have participated in since Donald
Trump was first elected to kind of fade
and the enthusiasm to wane we've got to
remember the opportunity is coming up
it's less than ten months away let's
talk not just about removing Donald
Trump but removing a malignant
Republicans from the Senate as well one
of the things I would love to see in
November of 2020 is a prominent
Republican senator defeated we know that
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
has multiple challengers it's an uphill
battle it's going to be a tough one but
it's one worth fighting there's another
interesting one which is South Carolina
Republican Senator Lindsey Graham whose
challenger Jamie Harrison raised more
than three and a half million dollars
during the fourth quarter of 2019 this
is more than listen to this he raised
more than any South Carolina Democrat
has ever raised in a quarter in the
history of South Carolina
he now has more than 4.6 million dollars
on hand
normal caveats here very often in red
states the Democratic challengers are
pretty
establishment types Jaime Harrison is a
centrist establishment type he's a DNC
official former chairman of the South
Carolina DNC campaign is backed by the
DSCC
but this is still good news because
Lindsey Graham has been one of the most
vocal Trump brown nosers during the last
thirty years culminating maybe with this
absolutely unhinged rant did I say 30
years I meant three years unhinged rant
in support of Donald Trump's often
accused of sexual assault Supreme Court
picked Brett Kavanaugh remember when a
Lindsey Graham appeared to have a
medical incident from how crazy he went
during those hearings take a look at
this if you wanted an FBI investigation
you could have come to us what you want
to do is destroy this guy's life hold
this seat open and hope you win in 2020
you said that not me
you've got nothing to apologize for
when you see soda Meyer and cake and
tell them that Lindsey said all because
I voted for them I would never do to
them what you've done to this guy this
is the most unethical sham since I've
been in politics and if you really
wanted to know the truth
you sure as hell wouldn't have done what
you've done to this guy are you a gang
rapist
no yeah so it would be a great
accomplishment to knock out Lindsey
Graham it is a huge uphill battle back
in 2014 in very red South Carolina
Lindsey won by 17 points 55 to 38 over a
grotto guy named Brad Hutto but Jamie
Harrison is raising more money Lindsey
Graham might have some liability hanging
on him because of his association with
Trump we just don't know yet
Jamie Harrison is a really long shot for
sure but anything can happen in any race
and a year the polls aren't looking
great at the the the polling we actually
have no really good polling in South
Carolina
we have a six-month-old poll a from
change research where Lindsey was
polling 70% but Jamie Harrison wasn't
even in that poll and now Jamie Harrison
has nearly 5 million dollars to spend
I don't think we can read too much into
the polling one way or the other other
to say other than to say it will be a
tough one it's fun to dream but imagine
if both Lindsey Graham and Mitch
McConnell were to lose their seats in
the same election cycle unlikely but
let's work every race like it's
potentially winnable the fact alone that
candidates for historically non
competitive Senate seats like South
Carolina and Kentucky are even able to
raise this much money tells us a lot
it's also sort of frustrating that some
candidates in more competitive states
like North Carolina and Georgia are
having trouble raising money that
actually is not good but let's remember
the lessons from the midterms of 2018
you know when when Democrats took over
the house in 2018 I remember that there
was satisfaction to some degree but also
kind of a feeling of helplessness like
what can what can we really do with
taking over the house Trump his
executive orders his cabinet the Senate
well because Democrats took over the
house in 2018 Donald Trump has been
impeached becoming only the third
president in history to be impeached now
that may go nowhere it may it certainly
is not likely to lead to Donald Trump's
conviction in the Senate it may help to
remove Donald Trump by voting him out in
November of 2020 but this is why every
single one of these races has to be
fought every single one of these Senate
races that could be taken from a
Republican has to be fought were only a
few seats from a majority in the Senate
I've looked at the numbers I've told you
it's tough
20:22 is more likely but we are given
that we're likely to lose one seat in
the Senate we only need to pick up five
in order to take over control it is not
impossible and we should be fighting for
it the 2018 midterms and Trump now being
impeached are Exhibit A as to why this
matters we have a voicemail number that
number is two one nine to david p
yesterday i talked about the cult-like
nature of trumpets both a cult of
personality around Trump but also the
very cult-like behavior of many of
trumps followers which includes
always finding reasons why the bad
things that Trump does aren't really bad
ignoring information about bad things
that Donald Trump does we talked about
it all before I got a voicemail
yesterday from at rumpus who says he is
not pleased with me making the cultist
analogy take a listen to this yeah I
just watched your show will you
lambasted tucker carlson and i'm a trump
supporter and there are 62 million of us
or 60 million of us yeah and you're
really condescending and insulting to us
that we're not smart enough to think on
our own or how we're gonna pay for
something I mean it's ridiculous the way
you talk about us that were a cult are
you kidding me I just melt no one's
gonna put me in a cult no politician is
going to brainwash me into voting for
them yeah I mean you know one of the
things that's important to understand
about cults is nobody who's in a cult
thinks they're in a cult
until sometimes after they've left the
cult no one who is brainwashed believes
that they have been brainwashed because
knowing you've been brainwashed would be
an antidote to the brainwashing and the
reality is a lot of people who voted for
Trump are ignorant people I I've said
before there's ignorant people on all
sides of the political spectrum
if someone in an uninformed way votes
for a Democrat or a progressive or
whatever it's not any less informed than
an ignorant Republican voter I would be
glad if they end up making the right
decision but there's uninformed and
ignorant voters on both sides but as I
said before there are basically three
categories of people who voted for
Donald Trump and I know this pisses a
lot of people off there are ignorant
people right people who just didn't know
what they were voting for they didn't
understand they were they either fell
for things Trump said that were
impossible and said this is why I'm
gonna vote for the guy without realizing
that the the they were impossible
promises or they just don't pay
attention to politics ignorance to some
degree there are people who are
cognitively limited and that again I'm
not insulting anybody it's just the
a lot of people in the electorate who
vote but they don't really have the
cognitive capacity to understand what is
going on it's not ignorance but it's a
limitation and then you have just what I
would call bad people and I know that
good bad is it's a very rudimentary and
unsophisticated way to categorize but
what I mean by bad people is it's not
people who are cognitively limited it's
not people who are ignorant to the facts
it's people who understand exactly what
it is that Donald Trump is promising and
they like it right they like it because
it's good for them personally because of
taxes for example or whatever those are
the three categories I've still not met
anyone to this day who voted for Trump
who doesn't fall into one of those three
categories and I will completely concede
to you that there are people on the left
at least with two of those three
categories that we could identify as
well prove me wrong I'm open to having
my mind changed we've got a great bonus
show for you today we will talk about
the repositioning of coalition forces
thanks to Donald Trump see Ron
belligerents we will talk about CNBC
using the wrong pictures on screen for
presidential candidates Andrew yang and
Tulsi Gabbard and we will also talk
about kids who have been shot after
throwing snowballs at passing cars this
reminds me of something former producer
Lewis and I used to do all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
get instant access by signing up at
joined pakman.com I'll speak to you that
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]